for the entire panel who does the best
Oliver as arrow voice impersonation who
does it yes Steven you don't do it
actually I talked about the situation
that we're going into is throw us a
curve at the end with the Hong Kong
twist and you had been planting kind of
hints throughout the first two seasons
that he did he spent his entire time on
that island is it safe to say that we
will not be seeing a lot of Island
flashbacks going forward well not
necessarily because when the show began
he was on the island so you know but for
this year you know we really wanted to
be a tease you know oh the new set of
bad guys showed up on Island again this
year how fortunate first or you know we
had we always had this plan and if you
watch season one and season two there's
gonna be even back in season one if it's
in the clear
111 Oliver says you know I got a message
from my father and planting this here
but it's you know it's a whole new
opportunity to put in new characters and
then there's characters that you've seen
previously on the show that will appear
in the flashbacks and the other great
opportunity is given us know Colin
Donnell is going to appear in the season
that is Tommy Merlyn and we're going to
tell the story of how a heretofore
unknown encounter between Oliver and
Tommy that that once you see it will
make sense and it's not a red card I
promise but you know it's just it's just
the whole new world that we've had and
all these new characters and that's
where Oliver will meet katana who were
just releasing this year played by
definitely okie and it's called moon
who's joining the cast and we'll see
we'll see how they're always doing so
that a get to the pretty girl I'm kind
of losing track of what my doors oh yeah
it's it's so easy loss is a terrible
time loving is closest with the things
that they're doing but you know he come
back people think that
she is doing I have not to tell you what
she's doing but can you at least tell us
how soon it will be we or we see ya
boy back together no cuz she's going to
be worth the wait I promise when you saw
her enter the limo with Malcolm at the
end of CC - we're going to basically
flashback to that moment and play the
rest of that scene apps so you're gonna
find out what he said to her and she
said this is the father of the thing the
caring the thing that the dig is going
to be walking through if it does - has
problems with him and team arrow he does
how kind of like a sidekick with some
other people who aren't so awesome but
very powerful witness and you know
super-powered kind of homage do you see
him going to kind of be like yeah I've
just become part of the Suicide Squad no
that's a great story it was a fantastic
story micro headshot figured about I
mean it's just been really really good
way the audience really responded with
that I think tables heart is here he's
just as invested I think and this crew
say is as Oliver is and and you see some
of that play out back actually one of
the scenes that they show the trailer
was a that fight between the Oliver a
big part of that is about how people
feels about his commitment to the city
and and this crusade so no I don't think
there's any chance of him deliberately
leading the team but alright it's
getting awfully crowded down in Oliver's
where more and more people is his
identity the worst kept secret in
Starling city you know for us the whole
Clark Clark you just miss Superman just
right here you know where were you is
the least interesting aspect of all of
these superhero stories so you know and
for us every time we made the decision
collectively that like it was time for
somebody to find out whether it was
Tommy or Laurel or Felicity all of a
sudden the show got a million times
easier to write and a lot more
interesting to us and so we've never
felt like you know Oliver secret
identity I feel like there are other
shows that have sort of trafficked and
add-ins and that's been buying for them
but you know for us it's much more
interesting when people know and they
can have conversations to be certainly
the season you know key Cassidy's
character and Laurel and Laurel and
Oliver's relationship and you know
laurels journey disease
everybody's gonna be really excited
about you know is far more interesting
that they can have realistic
conversations about everything without
you know having to hide so much for the
producers also do any plans of hair
someone lengthening coupling this
together just seems like last year with
you know see Brent it was out there you
know unhinged and D got to have you
scenes with some most fun seats right
and I think you guys are really can't
play the hell out you know because
that's a coupling that you don't
normally see
so as writers we're always looking to
care people who don't normally go
together right so going down the panel
from the actors from fall down I want
you to give us your favorite scene of
the person next to you so just to give
his favorite David performance
there's no way I can pin that one
particular see this guy says but I did
have my favorite moments when you're
filming with him and he has he said
there's one who season one I think this
is particularly dark sinister moment
ominous acutely er going on between us a
glance a peculiar moment dark and then
he goes
well here are recover Colton so I'm
going to cover melting in responses even
twice but I thought pause best that's
actually pretty easy it's so much you've
worked at fault but there was a great
scene where he or he thinks he has an
opportunity to be with his wife again
and and he does you guys don't see him
talking about and he's he's right there
you see on his face like oh I can really
be with you kid she's like no boo-boo
I have a new man and he's like oh you
see it all on his face is hard to break
so screen and it's fantastic work lean
on you show that I'm good
that's why they do you think that's
funny okay I think most of the people on
this panel we had the silver wire died
season I think she's got everybody on
this panel did some of their finest work
including Susanna Thompson who is who is
home the only reason she's no longer
with us is because we felt like that was
moyers time and for her to make that
sacrifice for her children but I think
that episode was a standout for every I
looked in the scenes that I could smell
from obviously do a lolly with Suzanne
and she was a wonderful lady wonderful
actress and a huge part of our teams
so you guys want to line up I just have
one last question for the producers
before we go to them I know it's super
early but have you started to like spit
ball ideas on how do you top the
undertaking and the finale battle that
we just saw the season like we're gonna
walk the world this is my first first of
all I just want to say this whole thing
is about super
I'm sitting in front of Harkness arrow
Dresden this is incredible but besides
those already been a pre-measured
Constantine who are superheroes you'd
like to see get their own shows or
appear on yours
that's great we've actually been really
blessed
DC Comics has been so supportive of us
Geoff Johns is partnered with us on the
flash and and you know we've gotten you
know Maddon katana this year you know
Robbie Amell who some of you might
remember Stephens cousin and the star
Tomorrow People is playing firestorm on
the flash so you know the kinds of
people that we wanted to bring on you
know
okay my name is Oliver five years I was
stranded on an island with only one goal
survive now we will return to Starling
city to fulfill my father's dying wish
and use the list of names he left me to
bring down those who are poisoning my
city
but to do this I can't be the killer I
once was
so honored my friends memory I must be
someone else I must be in the second
season with friends I must be something
else
go ahead
hi I'm gonna Bank down the show and I
love my question is if you were stranded
on the island who want you to choose
actor/actress to be with you let's just
go down the line well me of course I was
gonna say me too
yeah
not straight arrow
I would choose ventures weights we're
choosing people from the cats
I would be on the other because I really
like it was a person and I also like it
was an actor I James McAvoy and if it
was a girl
no for us I remember poison beam I'd be
so proud
did you do you weren't listening I was
like my seed you were not move in and
out of it is Joe I think Nyssa al Ghul
looks like a very practical question so
since you shoot an arrow
can you really shoot that well or is
that sniffs really good and people ask
me the question all the time like that
would win a contest between Katniss and
Hawk of course I would win
shots fired are you Trisha is the woman
that helps us with his archery chase
yeah a reasonable job I have serviced
one night we look at the quarries
holding this thing no rest of it looking
like nobody's doing anything and see
what this guy could run up to we'll run
up the wall shoot the arrows and still
hit the target so I think that's the
answer to question he knows what he's
doing
hi my name is Flavia Islam iam from
Pittsburgh nice hat
my question was family but she's not
here I guess it's very and remark it's
since we never really hit on her
backstory and the only thing she's never
really said about her dad is that he
wasn't around what are your theories
about Ivo being her father and that
rumor going around we never cross a
river we've actually known Felicity's
backstory for a long time and you know
again like some of the other things
we've done when you look back at stories
even from that's the season one there
are clues there but one of the early
episodes this season the flashbacks are
going to be to Felicity and her her time
at MIT
all right thank you and the title of the
episode is Oracle that's crazy I'm going
to thank our panel you guys use alone
thank you guys so much you're amazing